cervical cancer is one of the most  preventable types of cancer with regular  testing and is highly curable when found  early you can take action to avoid  exposure to HPV or human papilloma virus  the most common cause of cervical cancer  by limiting the number of people you  have sex with avoiding sex partners who  engage in high-risk activities delaying  sex until you're older and using condoms  to help prevent the spread of HPV and  other sexually transmitted diseases  avoid smoking which increases the risk  of cervical cancer in women infected  with HPV get vaccinated with Gardasil  which prevents infection with the two  types of HPV responsible for most cases  of cervical cancer get annual Pap tests  which look for precancerous changes on  the cervix that might develop into  cervical cancer if not treated in time  get the HPV test which tests for HPV in  the cervix be sure and talk to your  doctor about ways to reduce your risk of  cervical cancer